Katy Perry and fiance Orlando Bloom
already postponed their plans summer
wedding in Japan but in Australia the
show must go on the pregnant 35 year old
was photographed getting close with fans
down under that has led some followers
to call Katy irresponsible now that
she's expecting healthy pregnant women
do have immune and physiologic changes
that can make them more susceptible to
becoming severely ill if they get a
virus but I want to make it clear that
because this virus is new we don't have
a lot of research about pregnant women
but during an Australian podcast Katy
did admit her mom and dad have stopped
shaking her hand
my parents fist bumped me the other day
watching the news forever or will do I
guess and how is this for timing as the
world grapples with a potential pandemic
25 years ago today the film outbreak was
released
[Music]
et was on the 1994 set with Morgan
Freeman and Dustin Hoffman I hope that
the audience doesn't see this as fiction
I hope that they see this something else
that's going on today and today the 2011
film contagion is number seven on the
iTunes movie chart can you hear me but
in real life
experts say wearing a mask like co-star
Gwyneth Paltrow or Kim Kardashian
Priyanka Chopra and Kyle Richards does
little to protect from contracting the
virus this is one way to clear the
aisles for the everyday person that's
walking around without coronavirus no
it's not going to protect you from
getting it now who does need a mask you
do need a mask if you have been
diagnosed with corona virus or if you
are exhibiting symptoms of corona virus
[Music]